das ist q&d von meiner Reportage Hype um
Yoga es hat U4 kommentarge sich das
jetzt positiv oder negativ
starten wir Yoga das ist nämlich das wo
am meisten irgendwie diskutiert worden
ist
plantiful love meint das mit dem Bier
Yoga verstanden absolut nicht Alkohol
und Yoga das komplette Gegenteil
Nadine meint danke für diese Doku ich
habe selber eine vierjährige
berufsbegleitende Yogalehrerausbildung
in der Schweiz gemacht yoga ist für mich
in dieser Zeit zu einer
Lebensphilosophie geworden und die
heutige Angebote haben für mich oft
wenig mit dieser Philosophie zu tun es
geht um Äußerlichkeiten und Spaß Bier
Yoga würde man wohl kaum anbieten wenn
man die Yoga Sutras studiert hätte dann
haben wir draußen
richtig und falsches Yoga wer nimmt sich
das Recht raus über richtig und falsch
zu entscheiden Menschen die sich für
Bier Yoga anmelden wollen doch ganz
offensichtlich keine Tradition und das
ist okay so sich über diejenigen zu
stellen und sagen dass sie was falsches
tun finde ich jedoch überhaupt nicht
okay
mir bist du überhaupt nicht darum
gegangen dass ich irgendwie sagen das
ist es falsches Yoga und das ist
richtige Yoga mir ist wirklich darum
gegangen dass man das Wort Yoga verstaut
dass man sensibler ist auf das
Yoga auf das Wort und
verstaut das ist auch mehr ist als das
was man vielleicht denkt vielleicht aber
das tun oder die ewige das ist eben
erlaubend ich stelle geh ich
dann haben wir da einen Kommentar von
der Sabina Diesterweg
Haltungsnote B- für die sitzende Pose
und das noch mit Kissen nach 13 Jahren
oder bei der Lehrerin sogar 20 Jahre
Yoga sollte das etwas anders aussehen
peinlich
ja also ich finde nicht dass eben
Leistung
das ist das wo ich eigentlich vermittle
und egal ob man jetzt länger Yoga macht
oder eben nicht so lange
Unterstützung
wir sind in der Schweiz
wir haben in der Schweiz eigentlich so
eine Stuhlkultur mit sehr viel das heißt
auch wenn wir am bodenhockert und
meditierend den Fall du ist das mega
schwer und es grüßt sie unterstützt da
ist dass mir den einfachen konzentriert
konzentrieren aufs meditieren der cubav
Yogalehrer ist
er schrieb yoga ist eine Jahrtausend
alte Wissenschaft des menschlichen
Wohlbefindens es hat nichts mit Glauben
zu tun es wird gezielt mit Hilfe von
unterschiedlichen Übungen an innerer
erfahrungszustand des Wohlbefindens oder
Einheit erzeugt was viele Menschen über
unwege suchen Reichtum Karriere
Beziehung Drogen und so weiter wird im
Yoga bewusst durch Disziplin angestrebt
und ich glaube nachdem bin ich halt zum
yogahof hat zwar mega früh angefangen
mit Yoga wer kann ich von der Heilmittel
ich kann zum Teil mit Papi die Sachen
nachgemacht wo er vorzeigt hat er hat
zum Teil Yoga stelliger gemacht und ich
kann das einfach das Spaß nachgemacht
es ist einfach
was das ist und ich habe auch spürt dass
es nicht um Leistung geht und darum hat
man das irgendwie mega Spaß gemacht und
was man auch sagen ist
mit meiner Gefühl besser und das
wenn bis mal nicht so gut läuft dass es
nicht so schlimm ist und wenn ich mal
empfehle gemacht habe dass das
vielleicht nächste Mal besser geht und
das ist auch nicht so schlimm ist wenn
man nicht immer so schnell
diszipliniert sie und eben auch
konzentriert sie und das hat man
natürlich auch in der schulkäufe oder
jetzt im Alltag dann haben wir auch
Kommentar wo es darum geht warum ich auf
Bali bin und nicht in dir
man grobe Benzel meint der Kern der Doku
ist die Tradition von Yoga und man geht
anstatt ins Ursprungsland Indien nach
Bali und filmt eine weiße schlanke
Weißrussin beim Yoga
wollte da eine Journalistin ihre Doku
auch gleich mit einem Bali Urlaub
verbinden
ich befür das Halbjahr in Singapur sie
für den Sprachaufenthalt und bitte noch
Ferien gegangen auf Bali und dort habe
ich dann auch die Situation
machen über Yoga und außerdem
vor der coronazeit
also die meisten sind durchgegangen es
ist so die Nummer 1
und zum Beispiel
und das hat der Grund anscheinend das
einfach im Bali die Yoga Ferien einfach
günstiger sind
dann haben wir den lumpispace Brian
Celtics
viny Minute 28 auf der Wand rechts oben
ist sehr kritisch
wenn man das
ist das Bild und ich glaube er meint das
Kreuz überrascht und das Kreuz oberrecht
ist eigentlich eine kritisch es ist es
was dicker das ist mit vier schenken und
Hindus und Buddhisten
und aus Symbol vom Glück
Nazis hat das dann auch als braucht und
zu ihrem Symbol quasi erklärt und und so
eigentlich missbraucht worden dann haben
wir das Paar Kommentar wagte kulturelle
Aneignung
JuLis meint ich kann gut verstehen dass
der Missbrauch des Namens Yoga traurig
und vielleicht auch wütend macht ich
denke auch dass es wichtig ist dass zu
benennen wenn es sich um respektlose
Aneignung einer anderen Kultur handelt
letztendlich bin ich mir aber sicher
dass das traditionelle Yoga diesen
momentanen Hype überleben wird dass sie
nur Modeerscheinungen die auch wieder
verschwinden werden
Lara meint danke dass du so kritisch
warst ich finde das bier-yoga geht gar
nicht und das alpaka-yoga ist auch nicht
viel besser vor allem haben mich die
Einstellungen der Yogalehrerinnen
gestört es ist einfach schade dass Leute
doch so Sachen ein falsches Bild von
Yoga bekommen und somit Yogaerfahrung
leider verfälscht wird jeder soll das
machen was er oder sie möchte aber ich
finde auch dass man es anders benennen
darf danke für die für diese Reportage
Sarina schrieb auch wenn ich mir
wünschen würde dass viele sich der
Tradition bewusster wären freue ich mich
dass Yoga auf der ganzen Welt zu
verbreitet ist eventuell kann ein Besuch
im Bier Yoga Stand up Paddling Yoga
Alpaka Yoga etc Berührungsängste nehmen
und den einen oder anderen zum
traditionellen Yoga führen es kann also
auch eine Chance sein ich sehe der Punkt
die ich glaube genau das ist jetzt bei
dem Alpaka Yoga genau der Fall das
gewiss sich Hunde
Berührungsangst hat mit Yoga und darum
Mal töten
sie Yoga sind ich finde das ich finde
das mega cool wenn das so abläuft dann
haben wir Claudia ich habe vor 20 Jahren
in einem astraum von siebenanda Yoga
meine Ausbildung zur Yogalehrerin
gemacht
es war einfach wunderbar und als ich
zurückkam war ich eine andere ich
lächelte schon als ich von Paul Yoga
hörte nun gibt es sogar bio-yoga aber im
Endeffekt soll jeder das machen was ihm
Freude macht leben und leben lassen ich
finde eigentlich zu all dem ist mir
wieder so drum gegangen dass man auch
mit Toleranz hat und dass man ja
respektvoll mit dem Wort Yoga um Gott
und wenn man eben wenn man eigentlich
quasi sich informiert was das alles ist
und was dahinter steckt der finde ich
auch nicht dass
Ereignis ist ob es Gott darum dass man
eben sich informiert um was es überhaupt
geht wenn man das Wort braucht dann
haben wir
positive Kommentare von der Heidi
Schumann
danke vielmal für diese Sendung ich
denke auch dass der Weg nach innen zum
größten Teil vergessen geht beim
kommerziellen Yoga da wird meint
ausgezeichneter Bericht als Yogalehrer
bin ich von der Meinung dass Yoga von
Bewusstsein abhängig ist also Bier und
Alpakas lenken das sicher ab es sind
uviel positive Kommentaren mega gefreut
und unter anderem hat seine
Yogalehrerinnen und Yogalehrer
geschrieben hat und dass er nicht
natürlich mega cool gefunden wenn ihr
mehr so Reportagen